hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and long time listeners know that we do
a lot of different kinds of topics here
on the podcast but there is a heavy dose
of things like physics biology
philosophy
but if you think back the very first
episode was with a psychologist
carol tavris we've had a couple of
psychologists on since then
lisa feldman barrett scott barry kaufman
what we haven't
talked about on mindscape is
psychoanalysis
psychology is just the general study of
how people think how they behave and so
forth whereas psychoanalysis
is the specific set of ideas a school of
thought if you will
founded by sigmund freud and it's
actually weighed down by association
with
a lot of freud's ideas let's just say
aren't fully baked you know freud was
not right about everything he was
dramatically wrong about some things
so there's this sort of caricature of
psychoanalysis
uh with things like the edible complex
that men want to sleep with their
mothers penis envy that women have and
things like that things that haven't
held up
over time and in fact i think it's safe
to say that in
psychology circles there aren't a lot of
psychology professors who are in the
psychoanalytic tradition
these days but psychoanalysis lives on
in literary and certain philosophical
corners of
academia not as a way of necessarily
being a clinical practice although there
is that
but as a way of thinking about human
beings and how they behave in a way to
sort of understand ourselves
better and that's we're going to be
talking about today and to make things
worse
today's guest mari rudy is a professor
in the english department at the
university of toronto
she's the only person in the world who i
would trust
and to talk to you my audience about
these topics we're going to be talking
about today because it's not just
psychoanalysis
it's the particular kinds of
psychoanalysis that are influenced and
thought about by
french theorists most especially jacques
lacan
a famous french psychoanalyst and a
literary critical theorist etc
and these ideas you know again i'm
pretty sure that most of the folks here
in my audience
are not by nature sympathetic
to these kinds of ideas isn't that like
post-modernism and all this anti-science
anti-real world
stuff so what i ask you is to listen
to the podcast that is in front of you
because mari is the best in the world
at taking that set of ideas and making
them clear
and helping us understand which subset
of that set of ideas are actually
worth listening to and you might not at
the end come away
buying it that's completely fine right i
don't ask you to buy it the
idea of mindscape is that i don't even
buy everything that people who i have on
are going to be talking about right i
don't buy everything that
lee smolin or david chalmers actually
says but i respect what these people
have to say and if i don't understand
something
i want to give it a charitable careful
listen
before i make my decisions and if you at
all
are at all interested in understanding
the set of ideas better and would like
to
think about it carefully and know enough
about it to make your own judgments
you've come to the right place you know
and actually i'm even being too negative
to say that i think there are
really good really important ideas here
that can
influence how we think about ourselves
in
interesting ways you know in the middle
of this episode i asked mari to indulge
me a little bit and i made an extended
analogy
between laconia and psychoanalysis and
entropy in the arrow of time and out of
equilibrium physics
and this it may or may not uh stand up
to higher scrutiny but
it's the kind of thing i think is
interesting and worth thinking about and
so with that in mind let's go
mari rudy welcome to the mindscape
podcast well thank you for having me um
it's really an honor to be invited i'm
very grateful
to have this conversation with you sure
i think it's gonna be a lot of fun
because it is a bit of a departure you
know i end up saying at the beginning of
half of my podcast this is a departure
from what we usually do
so maybe it's a little bit uh maybe i
should just uh
qualify the the boundaries as wider away
than they really are but
anyway so the let's just dive into
perhaps
the most the thing that's going to
happen to the minds of the audiences
when they hear what we're talking about
which is the word psychoanalysis
right i mean this is a fraught word in
the modern
age we we instantly think about a
hundred years ago sigmund freud
patients on a couch freud telling them
that if they're guys
they want to have sex with their mother
if they're women they have penis envy or
something like that
and a lot of this uh has been the
subject of enormous criticism over many
many years
uh and so much so that many people have
abandoned it but there's a bunch of
people who want to say
that there are valuable insights there
uh when we take some of these ideas and
put them into a more modern context
you're one of those people so i mean how
about just starting with the general
sales pitch for why we should take
psychoanalysis seriously here at the
first fifth or first quarter of the 21st
century
okay so the entire time you were talking
i
had to suppress my laughter because i
didn't want to laugh over you
everything you say everything everything
that you say is right
um i can just imagine your listeners
already like rolling their eyes
at the very word psychoanalysis and i'm
very used to this resistance because i
teach the topic to undergraduates every
year
so i get a new bunch of people every
single semester
who have only heard um snippets about
psychoanalysis and usually not
not the good parts so they know things
like you know freud used cocaine and
they know about penis envy and
stuff like that but they don't really
know much about it um
but then i have to admit that or i guess
i
should say i'm proud of the fact that
within three weeks i will have
re-inculcated them i will have
indoctrinated them to the point that
my colleagues in the hallway start
telling me to stop talking about some of
the
concepts because apparently the students
who are in my classes
can't stop talking about the
psychoanalytic concepts that i have
introduced
them to in their other classes which
then drives my colleagues crazy
so so i know how how to break the
resistance but i'm not sure i'm able to
do this
during this very podcast um but i will
just
start by saying that there are actually
a lot of academics on the level of
professors and graduate students who are
combining psychoanalysis with
usually with continental philosophy and
contemporary theory
and in some ways it's difficult for us
to think about a time
before um the current version of
psychoanalysis took over the humanities
and to some extent even the social
sciences
um there was a period when it was like a
complete no-no
like serious academics did not take it
seriously but
these days a lot of people in the
humanities and even some in the social
sciences do
but it's a very specific version of
psychoanalysis um
so um i'm gonna mostly be drawing on
a french thinker um a post-freudian
psychoanalyst and theoretician called
jacques lacon his last name is spelled
l-a-c-a-n in case no one has heard of
him
but he's among the uh i would say
top like 10 most famous french thinkers
of the 20th century which is saying a
lot
you can compare him to people like satre
or te bevoir
derida foucault people like that and he
was part of the revolution
that happened in the american academy in
the humanities during the
80s and 90s when french theory kind of
took
the american academy um like
uh like a big wave um like a storm
um and there was a lot of resistance but
also there
like i said there's like kind of no
going back to the pre-cycle analytic
moment um because it did transform
transform so many fields
sorry i know that you're right in the
beginning of of this but let me just
just again so we can orient the audience
um
and i i've resisted this but i think
that there's a lot of people out there
who maybe don't know about the
resistance but
there's this feeling this caricature
that that exact
uh wave of french influence of sort of
post-modernism and post-structuralism
that came to the u.s in the 80s and 90s
is all about just denying the existence
of reality and saying there's no such
thing as truth and you can't do anything
i think that is not where you're coming
from but maybe point that out
or or tell me that you are coming yeah
no that's that's uh thank you so much
that's an excellent um
excellent clarification uh to ask for
um one reason that i'm uh attracted to
psychoanalysis specifically is that
it's the one component of that so-called
post-structuralist theory
that did not give up on uh a lot of
things that i did not want to lose i
feel like
post-structuralism say darida and fukuo
those people
they got rid of things like truth and
uh also like in some ways psychological
complexity and psychological life it
became all about power and signifiers it
became very very cold
like the human being just got kind of
taken out of the equation
as did any understanding of uh
truth and um i mean the psychoanalytic
understanding of truth is very different
from your understanding of it but at
least in lacanian theory there is such a
thing and it has to do with the truth of
desire which i
i can talk about later but uh that's
probably not the best
place to start right off the bat um i do
want to talk about desire though so
we'll get back to that
but yeah psychoanalysis uh drew me
specifically because it did not
take away all those things that the rest
of post-structuralist theory did
um and it's all only really specialists
who understand that there's a
distinction between someone like lacan
and someone like jacques nereida
a lot of people lump them together but
um those of us who study the field
understand that they are coming from
very different places well and again
okay
yeah that's that sounds perfect thank
you very much for that clarification
the other thing that people are going to
be uh raising their hackles about
is don't these people intentionally try
to be
impossible to understand and
i know that your whole thing like the
thing you're famous for is making these
uh impossible to understand things
understandable which is why we have you
on the podcast and not
the ghost of jacques khan
yes i i do i do have the reputation for
being
like the one lucid likanian um
the one person who can well there are
others but people often email me and say
oh wow i write your book and this is the
first time i ever understand
lacan um he's one of the most
incomprehensible
uh he's probably the most
incomprehensible
of the all of all of all of the income
principle thinkers
in french theory uh he is
like when i when i um
when i asked my graduate students to
read one of his
books they will come to class and say
i didn't understand any of this i
literally did not understand more than
five percent of this
and that was my own experience also when
i started reading him but over the years
i've gotten
pretty good at deciphering what he had
to say and okay so the the
short answer to the question um that
you're asking
uh it kind of has well it has two
components
post-structuralism um broadly speaking
was interested
in subverting the idea that
meaning is transparent so they started
writing intentionally in this completely
incomprehensible
aggravatingly opaque way to make people
struggle
with uh the idea that they could
understand everything that they read
so that's one component kind of a
political ethical component
and then what and that had to do with
like taking down
uh western epistemological models that
were
uh you know centered around a certain
type of clarity and
certain type of uh logical reasoning but
then when you come to
lacan himself um it also has to do with
the fact that he
intentionally wanted to speak the
language of the unconscious which is
basically
gibberish which is why many of his
lectures sound like complete gibberish
so you have to kind of allow yourself to
enter into that space
of the unconscious to understand
anything that he's saying it's very
intuitive
um and if you're trying to kind of go at
it with
logic in mind you're never gonna you're
not gonna get anywhere
but yeah that's a really good question
okay i'll let you resume the
psychoanalysis
glossary okay so i wanted to say right
off the bat that
um i am not interested personally i'm
not i'm not interested in things like
gender and sexuality and the oedipus
complex and penitentiary and stuff like
that i think that those are outdated
concepts
um i'm also not interested in claiming
that psychoanalysis
is some sort of a science because i i
mean
freud was a neurologist before he became
a psychoanalyst and
i know that there's some work in
contemporary neuroscience that
is drawing connections to freudian
thought
in interesting ways but i'm not an
expert on those um
for me uh psychoanalysis is kind of a
philosophy of everyday life it's a
mythology of
human ontology what it is that makes us
who we are what causes us to behave
in the ways that we behave um so think
of it as a mythological
thing rather than an attempt to give you
a scientific basis for anything
take it with a grain of salt um at the
same time
it has incredibly um
like in my opinion really insightful
points to
to make about um human beings and
everyday life and i'm just going to
mention
three points really quickly and then
hopefully you can
uh prompt me with further questions um
so the things that most interest me
about latinian theory specifically and
also
more broadly psychoanalysis but he does
have a specific take that i can also
talk more about in a bit but um the
three things that i take
from his theory specifically um
are first of all the fact that he
understands
he understands human anthology to be
based on
this sense sense that we are lacking
something that there is this emptiness
or
hollowness or um nothingness within our
being
and as you know uh people like jean
jean-paul had the same idea i mean his
famous book is called being in
nothingness so lagan is not the only
person to think in those terms but
he had a very good explanation for why
we we feel like that uh why
why we feel like we have lost something
kind of unfathomably precious
that we cannot get back and that and
then
the idea is that because of that lack we
have desire
and because of desire we try to seek all
kinds of ways of
filling that lack um including things
like writing books or
creative endeavors or other intellectual
endeavors or whatever it is that makes
human life
sort of um meaningful to people hosting
podcasts that's the first
hosting podcast sorry hosting podcast is
what makes life meaningful i think here
in 2021
that's a really good okay so you are
that's your way you're filling your life
because i have done it in many other
ways like writing a gazillion uh books
as i have so we have that in common but
that's definitely
i know that that's like my pathology
that that's my symptom writing books is
my symptom
it's the only way i can deal with the
ontological nothingness
um okay that was the first point second
is that um
lacan came to the conclusion that unlike
during freud's time
we are no longer living in a society of
repression so freud talked about sexual
repression and how
we become symptomatic when our sexuality
is repressed in various ways and lacan
was like
because he was writing in the 50s 60s
and 70s and he was like that's no longer
the case in our society
our problem is actually the the um
opposite
meaning that we are inundated with
enjoyment what he called enjoyment
and we have just like almost too many
sources of enjoyment
available to us like every every
possible kind of porn is available to us
on the internet so it's not like our
sexuality is repressed
uh rather we're kind of overwhelmed by
the abundance of possibilities for
satisfaction okay so that was
the second point and then the third and
i'll say this quickly
because there's a lot here to unpack but
um i think that psychoanalysis
is really excellent at explaining like
any psychoanalysis specifically it's
really excellent at explaining
uh various components of everyday life
such as desire
love this is how i hook my students
right away i start talking about desire
and love and they're like oh please give
us
give us more trauma loss
alienation mourning melancholia
depression
and also importantly um the way in which
we tend to repeat
hurtful patterns of behavior even when
we really
don't want to repeat them we keep doing
it anyway we tell ourselves that we're
going to
change our way of doing things but
somehow we can't
and psychoanalysis is good at
explaining that through what freud
already
theorized as the repetition compulsion
okay i will pause there and give you a
test speak
applying for jobs can be incredibly
stressful but hiring people can also be
stressful
getting the right people into your
organization can make or break whatever
it is you're trying to do
that's where indeed comes in indeed is a
job site that makes hiring
incredibly simple with indeed you do all
your hiring in one place
attracting hiring even interviewing
indeed's hiring tools help you cut
through the noise to hire faster and
smarter in fact
indeed instant match provides a list of
quality candidates whose resumes are on
indeed
the moment you post a sponsor job with
indeed assessments you can choose from
over 135 skills tests
to help make sure you're finding
applications from people with the skills
you need
join more than 3 million businesses
worldwide that use indeed to hire great
talent fast
and you can get started right now with a
75 dollar sponsored job credit
to upgrade your job post at indeed.com
mindscape that's a 75 credit at
indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through september
30th terms and conditions apply
go to indeed.com mindscape
yeah no i mean there's a there's a
tremendous amount there and i hope we're
going to get a chance to go through
all of it but before we dive into these
specifics with
with those points in mind you know let's
say a little bit more about
the general angle that we're taking here
i mean i like it that you said very
explicitly
you're not pretending to be a scientist
right that was one of the
criticisms of freud in particular is
that he really really really wanted to
be
taken seriously as a scientist and the
the fellow scientists are like ah
predict something that that i wouldn't
have been able to predict otherwise
uh otherwise i'm not going to take you
too seriously but if you reformulate
the approach as more of a i'm not even
sure if it's a philosophy of life but as
a set of insights that are relevant to
the philosophy of life
then it seems to make more sense to me
it is and that's what maybe one of the
reasons why it was very popular
in literature in english departments as
opposed to philosophy or neuroscience
departments and it actually for other
reasons i've been reading
don't take me too seriously here because
it's not very deep reading but i've been
reading some
early chinese philosophy and you know
these people are very brilliant and and
the warring states period and confucius
and uh zhuangzu etc but
uh but they're not the sort of setting
up systems of logic or political ethics
that we
that we think of as the standard western
version of philosophy it's much more
like
living your life and maybe part of this
is just reclaiming the idea that
understanding how to live your life
is a very valuable endeavor
absolutely first of all i should say
that
uh lithuanian theory has very um
deep connections to eastern philosophy
the whole idea of
being being being kind of built around a
void or nothing
that's um central to a lot of western i
mean sorry eastern philosophy
but yeah um i do like to think about it
as a
philosophy of uh everyday life and
when cab drivers inevitably ask me what
i
what i write on or what i teach i tell
them that
um i work on the meaning of life and
then they ask me
what is the meaning of life and i say
well the meaning of life is that there
is no meaning
so that's that's usually how the
conversation goes
however i even though in some ways there
is no meaning there is
a a lot of like bits of meaning to be
drawn
um from this particular way of looking
at the world
and one thing i forgot to mention in my
introductory
uh comments that i do want to get out is
that
when lacan started writing in the 1950s
um and he also started giving annual
uh lecture series um and they went on
for like 30 years and
initially he had a very tiny audience
that was composed of
such just specialists but he very
quickly uh
developed a reputation in paris so in
the 1960s and 70s when
paris was really uh like the parisian
intellectual community was
generating a lot of really interesting
ideas philosophical ideas
and in in their view psychoanalysis was
part of philosophy
so during those two decades pretty much
anyone who was anyone in the parisian
intellectual scene in the humanities and
some of the social sciences
attended his lectures which became huge
and so he had an impact on a whole
generation of french thinkers that came
just slightly after him like he was he
was kind of
petering out in the late 70s and people
like darida started writing in the late
60s so
he influenced the whole generation of
thinkers
and it that influence had a lot to do
with that notion of lack
that i keep referring to do i remember
correctly the anecdote that lacan at
some point
uh came to give a lecture and then once
everyone was assembled he just stood
there silently for an hour and then he
left
is that a true story yes yes absolutely
so he had
he has a reputation for being a
troublemaker a maverick uh just kind of
a crazy person who would you also do
things like
throw items at the audience members like
books and uh
pens and pencils and stuff like that and
uh toward the end of his life when he
was
becoming very interested in math and you
laugh at this and i know that
this is a part of like on that i don't
really touch except for the content
because i don't understand any of
his mathematical equations but his
very late work is full of math
mathematical equations
and when i talk to specialists who under
actually understand math they claim that
they don't really make any sense
which i understand because also his
written text doesn't make any sense
but why should i the reason i'm talking
about this is that he came to new york
city
i think it was new york um he gave a
major talk
and he stood on the stage playing with
knots because he was interested in not
theory and math at that point and so he
didn't say anything he was just standing
there
and playing with these knots with like
ropes and stuff like that
and finally his audience just kind of
gave up and left
so yeah he was he was an eccentric
a brilliant eccentric it does remind me
this is completely non-substantive and
just
silly but it reminds me of the story
about dara da who gave a talk
at some point uh uh i was in the united
states so he was speaking in english not
his first language and he was always
apologetic about his english
and he for some reason he was given this
entire talk about
cows and the whole audience is like why
why is he talking about cows like i
don't know what cows have to do with
what he's saying
and then you know he ends the talk and
then uh it's the question period and
he talks to the organizer or whatever
the moderator and
and then he comes back to the microphone
and says i'm informed and it's
pronounced
chaos
that's perfect that's perfect sense yes
so you have to
yeah just do some exegesis you have to
do some little work here but
good so uh yeah two more points i wanted
to sort of
you sort of big picture points before we
get into your into your more details
one is the idea that even though you're
not claiming to be a scientist and and
you're not following freud in that way
um there clearly is science that is
relevant here uh right we've learned a
lot more about neuroscience than we have
learned before and the specific point
that you raise
uh that reminded me of that was the uh
repetition compulsion
instinct whatever it is uh what do i
call it the repetition compulsion
yeah that's right okay um that's
something that is absolutely you know
based in neuroscience and in fact i had
a very interesting podcast with robin
carhart harris who uses
psychoactive drugs uses lsd and other
things to help treat
those kinds of things so i'm a believer
that sort of both
approaches are valid i mean if we
understand these things qualitatively
and can sort of come to grips with
what's going on that's valid
and if we understand what's going on in
the neurons that's also helpful
yeah that's that's really great and so
now i'm going to go back to freud
because i mean one of his kind of ground
pro
groundbreaking ideas that i think is
still relevant today is that he had this
idea that
our bodies or our drive energies
have been wired in specific pathways
and um it's possible for those pathways
to become really
fixed and that's part of what he meant
by symptomatic behavior
and that's partly what he meant by the
repetition compulsion you're gonna
hardwire to
repeat i mean like mentally by hard wire
to repeat certain kinds of
uh actions but also like on a physical
level
like um i'll use myself as an example
you know me pretty well
i've always been someone who has an
excess of energy
uh la khan calls this jesus it's just a
french word for like pleasure
but it can be pleasure that is so
intense that it's kind of painful
and uh so um basically
freud already had this idea that you
know your
our pathways of energy juices whatever
you want to call it
are configured in specific ways
and the whole point of psychoanalysis as
a clinical practice like when people go
to analysis for years and years and
years
is to reconfigure those pathways is to
break the usual pathways
and create new ones and that absolutely
has to do with neuroscience
and i wish that i knew more about the
current research that is being done in
the field
because i know that there is a lot that
is being done that is
that is explicitly comparing
psychoanalytic
findings to current neuroscientific
findings and i know that they are
finding interesting
overlaps i just don't know enough about
neuroscience to
be able to speak to any specifics but i
do know that
the the breaking of those patterns and
breaking of those kind of
pathways through your body and your
psyche was
at the chest of what freud was trying to
accomplish
yeah no it sounds like there's a lot of
uh fruitful things to be thought about
there okay and the final big picture
uh question or point i wanted to raise
was um when you talk about
the existentialist uh sort of angle here
and the i don't know it's not really
nihilism or despair but it's a search
for meaning when when meaning has been
lost to us so
this uh circles back to questions of
atheism and religion and things like
that right i mean is
part of the need for this analysis that
we now live in a world uh where god is
dead and
we need to i mean i'm certainly a big uh
proponent that we need to construct uh
not only purpose and meaning but also
morality and ethics and
things like that and this is part of
that overall project is that fair yeah
that's really fair
i mean i agree with you uh on everything
that you just said
um and i think that uh
on some level what at least
likania psychoanalysis is trying to do
is to allow us to
figure out how to deal with that lack
within our being without resorting to
some sort of a theological
or otherwise sort of otherworldly
explanation
or an attempt to uh cope with it or
even cure it you know the it makes
perfect okay so
if we start from the premise that he
gives us meaning that
we feel like there's this void within
our being then you can see how religion
would be an incredibly seductive um
ideology uh the idea of of an
afterlife where you kind of reward it
for your
present suffering it's an incredibly
seductive way to deal with that lack and
i think a lot of people do
deal with it that way however what is
distinctive about
lacanian analysis and this is why
he's beloved by a lot of academics in
america but
he's not really popular with a lot of
american clinicians because
he basically argued that
that the best way we can handle this
sense of lack is to acknowledge that
there is no cure for it
that we just have to learn how to cope
with it and the idea was that
as as soon as you acknowledge the
impossibility of a cure
you could actually start devoting your
energies to things that
make your life meaningful and i
mentioned writing books
uh you mentioned podcasts uh but
i mean not everyone and not everyone is
an intellectual or an artist you know
painting paintings and writing books and
stuff like that
uh people have various ways of uh
finding meaning in their lives uh that
are sort of
more everyday than what we intellectuals
do but the point is that
he was trying to give his patients and
also
his audience members the ability to
think about how to make their lives
meaningful
without resorting to the idea of god
right
that said he was very knowledgeable
about christianity
and i think was born catholic but he was
still an
atheist um so it's a complicated
relation to
religion uh but definitely like a
secular
uh secular attempt to deal with
this nothingness within our being and to
understand this nothingness as a kind of
a springboard for
everything that is meaningful about
human life including desire and
love and our capacity to connect with
other people i can explain all of that
in more detail if you want but
it was kind of like this idea that the
lack was not our enemy it actually was
the the foundation of everything good
about human life
so actually that's exactly what i do
want uh to hear you expound on a little
bit more but if you will indulge me for
a minute
uh i want to propose an analogy or maybe
it's even an equivalence with uh physics
concepts here because it's just not okay
and i'm really scared yeah that's what i
think about the world
um and but but but i'll creep up on it
by talking a little bit about antonio
damasio who is a previous uh guest i had
on the podcast and he's a neuroscientist
uh and so his way his his big words
are homeostasis and feelings
uh and what what he means by this is so
when i translate that into physics terms
what he means by this is this
you know if you have a box of gas this
is a typical physicist move you have a
box of gas
you let it reach equilibrium it becomes
comes to a temperature
and it'll just sit there forever like if
you seal the box away from the outside
world it's fine it's going to stay in
exactly that
condition for all time but we human
beings or any living
living being we're not like that we're
not equilibrium systems that we can seal
off like if you see a less off
we will die and at the very fundamental
physiological level
we need food and we need air and we need
uh things like that and then so this is
what demacio is talking about
homeostasis is the attempt to more or
less regulate
our physiology into its proper zone
um but it's something that needs to be
an active
process it won't you need to get fuel
you need to get the right kinds of
stimulation etc
and to me the psychological version of
that sorry there is a psychological
version of that
also uh and this is where feelings comes
in he you know he
his word for feel the reason why he
cares about feelings rather than
emotions is he thinks of feelings as the
sort of
more primitive impulses that your body
and brain are giving you saying
something's not quite right let's fix it
a little bit right
the this deviation from homeostasis and
so
like so so the physics lingo is
human beings are out of equilibrium
systems we we have some
more or less steady state but it's like
in my analogy it's like you're a
surfer riding a rate away if it's not
like you're a rock on the beach
you need to continually do little
adjustments right to make sure you don't
fall off
and so that's why so coming back to what
you've said sorry for uh
for taking over a little bit but um
that's why i
like this emphasis on the fact that we
shouldn't be seeking the once and for
all cure
that's like saying we should be seeking
the state of being where we don't eat
anymore right
uh we are constantly going to be lacking
something driven to sort of fulfill some
extra
desire we're not we're not reaching a
state of perfect happiness
and that's okay that's part of the
process once you realize that human
beings are out of equilibrium systems
so what about that that's my question
well okay once again i agree with
everything you said if i understood it
correctly
and that's a really interesting way of
thinking about
the matter i mean so to translate this
into like psychoanalytic terms
when when people go to analysis it's
usually because they feel like they are
off balance they are out of equilibrium
in one way or another and
they are seeking to figure out how to
fix that
i mean most commonly they go in because
they feel like they're not being loved
or they're not being loved in the right
way but
anyway uh something is off kilter and
um so a lot of the process
psychoanalysis
uh it's not the most efficient i was
going to say this when you talked about
neuroscience because i know that the
neuroscientific solutions and like
cognitive
behavioral adjustments are much faster
and more efficient
psychoanalysis is very inefficient in
the sense that it takes years
but the point is precisely to gradually
uh make sure that you maintain
a degree of or at least first first of
all you introduce a degree of
equilibrium into
the patient's kind of psychic and bodily
existence and that
then you kind of i think in the process
what's supposed to happen is that the
patient the client
learns how to self-regulate so
the end of analysis is basically when
you're able to
do it yourself you don't need the
analyst's help to
um to reach a certain degree of
equilibrium
in the understanding that you're always
going to lose it you're not never going
to be able to hold on to it permanently
like you just said
and the trick is precisely to be okay
with that and to give yourself the
permission to be
fine with that at the same time as you
seek as
as much as you can a certain degree of
like comfort zone or equilibrium like i
mentioned earlier that i have this
huge excess of energy and my struggle is
constantly to
contain it and like kind of
tame it uh to a certain degree and
uh going to analysis actually is it like
an analysis
helped me learn how to do that in a
better way
which then did things like reduce the
amount of physical pain that i was in
uh which was a symptom of like this over
agitation and so yes
that all of that makes perfect sense and
has uh
obvious um like analogies with uh
psychoanalytic thinking this over
abundance of energy is just not the
problem that i'm faced with in my life
i'm sorry that you know that
it's a good reminder that people are
different from each other we have all of
our own little
issues um but so good so
then uh i want to hear more about these
lacks um
you know so i understand the abstract
idea
i mean there's the danger that it's just
too general and too broad to be useful
to say well there's something you don't
have and you want it
okay i mean that's a pretty that's a
pretty general thing like how about how
much more specific
can we be about the kind of lacks or the
origin of these lacks that are relevant
to typical
people trying to get through the world
okay
okay great question um the first thing i
want to say is that i
in my own work which is different from
the work of this is one of the
differences between
my work and the work of some other
latinos is that
i tend to focus on two very different
levels of lack
i want to distinguish between what i'm
calling ontological
lack a kind of constitutive foundational
lack that is
supposedly universal to human beings
um that's on the one hand and then on
the other hand
there are all kinds of context specific
context specific or circumstantial forms
of lag that people
are like wounding that people suffer
from various kinds of injury
that may be systemic like racism or
poverty or sexism
or maybe like idiosyncratic to you
having to do with say your
uh upbringing your family maybe you had
a traumatic upbringing as a child
stuff like that and that's a different
level of lack from the ontological
uh version that lacan usually focuses on
so that's
kind of the preface and then i guess um
um if you wanna if i if it's okay i'll
dig a little deeper about how he
comes to that understanding of lack as
the foundation of existence
i mean he basically and it's just like
the cliff notes version
of the the chest of likanian theory
on human ontology the idea is that when
the
infant is born into the world uh it's
born into a world of
signifiers of meaning when i mean when i
say signifiers
i don't mean just language but but also
like non-verbal cues
uh smiling and how people hold the
infant and stuff like that
um but a lot of these meanings uh pre
exist that that i mean almost all of
them pre
exist the infant's arrival in the world
and one good example is
gender where sometimes parents um
unless they are very you know
forward-looking
they paint their nurseries
different colors depending on whether
they are expecting a boy or a girl they
will buy different toys
depending on whether it's boy or a boy
or girl so that's a really clear example
of how signifiers in some ways
determine the child's being on some
level even before it arrives into the
world
and then the idea is that once the st
once the child starts to learn how to
speak and
starts to understand language language
is key
key for here language is really key for
lacanian theory
his idea was that once the child starts
to speak
it quickly comes to realize that it's
actually not the center of the world
uh because before language there's just
there's no distinction between the world
and the child the child is sort of the
entire universe the entire world
but once there's language there's
suddenly me and there's you
and there are like objects in the world
and
that is what he thought was the
the kind of the source of the feeling
that we have lost something unfathomably
precious that we have lost the sense of
plenitude of being
whole suddenly we are no longer whole um
and once that happens uh the desire to
feel that
that void kicks in and you start looking
for various ways to
to feel that feel that void feel that
nothingness
and as i said earlier his idea was that
the best thing you can do is to just
learn to live with it rather than
try to heal it um so that's the really
really short
uh version of why he thought that we are
the way we are
and that's different from that make that
immediately makes us different from uh
other like other animals um i think that
lacan would have agreed that
humans are animals on on various levels
but
because of this sophisticated uh usage
of language and
signifiers that we have he um
he implied that we are and i'm using
wording from
a fellow likeanian todd mcgowan
who says that human beings are distorted
animals and that has to do with the
idea that language has somehow meddled
with our biology
in such a way that we are no longer in a
kind of pure biological state but we
have been
distorted by uh the culture that we are
we were born into
and that our feeling of like okay we're
missing something there's like a piece
of me missing
is a part of that distortion that other
animals
presumably don't experience
we all spend a lot of time writing
online whether it's applying for a job
or just sending something out to social
media
and we're not always at our best when it
comes to the wordsmithing
that's where word tune comes in word
tune is the first
ai powered online writing tool that
actually
understands what the words mean i use
word tune when i'm writing emails
all you have to do is type in your draft
highlight a sentence
and word tune comes up with suggested
alternatives to how to
structure those sentences so they are
crisp clear and strong
all of us fall into ruts when we're
writing we use the same constructions
over and over again
word tune can help you escape those ruts
and wordtune works anywhere you're
working online google docs slack outdoor
web
whatsapp and more and mindscape
listeners can try wordtune for free
at wordtune.com mindscape if you're away
from your computer
go to wordtune.com mindscape on your
mobile phone
enter your email and they'll send you a
link to make it easy to get started
so get help writing your emails reports
presentations resumes and blogs today
go to wrdtune.com
mindscape
part of that makes a lot of sense to me
and part of it uh i i i can't quite
sign on to but maybe i just don't know
enough about it the the
this this distinction between humans and
other animals
there's something to that because you
know i mean animals can be happy or sad
they could be frightened or whatever
they don't get embarrassed
that much or they don't feel social
anxiety in quite the same way that we do
they don't worry about the future
in the same way that we do and and i've
i've sometimes discussed it not in terms
of
language but in terms of our imaginative
capacities to uh
think about the future which is which is
part which is wrapped up in the in the
whole language thing so i think that
there is something there that is very
interesting
and worth diving into even more uh that
what i
what i'm more skeptical about is the
story about
uh the baby uh coming into the world and
being surrounded by signifiers i mean
clearly that's true
um whether or not or
let's put it this way which aspects of
my current
or someone else's current psychological
makeup can be
traced to that occurrence in my infancy
seems to be to be almost impossible to
know i mean it's a it's a good story but
how would i know if that were true and
how i know there's some other story that
isn't
that isn't just as good i mean is is
that part of the story crucial to the
later insights or is it more like uh
it's all part of a package and we can
take in and leave some different parts
of it
yeah that's a really good question i
think i think that it is pretty
foundational to
likanian theory specifically
um and i think i mean i think that a lot
of it is actually kind of intuitive
in the sense that a lot of people would
come to your analysis
and complain about the fact that they
feel like something is missing from
their
being that they are feeling this
emptiness or you know
some sort of alienation or um like
existential malaise or
males or like dissatisfaction and so i
think he was looking for an explanation
for that
um because other animals don't have like
existential i don't know but it looks
like
it seems like they don't have
existential anxiety and all of these
worries about this and that and so he
was trying to
figure out why um and you know
like i said earlier philosophers who are
writing around the same time as he was
writing and thinking came to the same
conclusion
uh that there is this kind of a feeling
of void that human beings
seem to share but they weren't really
able to explain it and so one of the
things that lacan was trying to do
through that theory of of language
acquisition
had to do with that attempt to explain
why it is that we end up like that
and uh yeah so um i
like i said at the beginning this is i i
take all of this
with a grain of salt it is a mythology
to me
um i acknowledge that there could be all
kinds of other explanations
uh but it also seems
feasible that uh once
once the child begins to speak it
loses something and one another way to
think about this is that
because because of the cognitive
distinction between uh
very young children and adults a lot of
times children don't really understand
what it is that adults want from them so
uh lakan talks
in terms of like enigmatic signifiers
the signifier that is coming at the
child
is enigmatic uh the child can't process
exactly what it is that the other wants
the other being the parent or the other
caretaker or whoever
what is it what did what it is they want
from the child
and so that itself can lead to a certain
degree of kind of unease or
of being off balance or in this this
equilibrium that you described earlier
um but yeah i'm not asking anyone to
believe this as some sort of a
scientific uh fact it's definitely a
theory
um and uh you know there are
other psychoanalytic thinkers like
melanie klein who worked
with very young children and infants uh
they're like child psychiatrists and
child
psychoanalysts who arrived it's
at similar um conclusions using
different vocabulary
uh from like formula canadian theory and
that was
um those observations were based on
actually like looking at how young
infants
react to stimuli coming from the outside
world again i'm not an expert on this
but i know that
infant psychoanalysts have arrived at
some of the same conclusions
interesting again not a science
definitely not a science okay that's
okay
but uh okay good so we have this lag may
or may not come from
uh look i i completely
think it's plausible that childhood
experiences
imagination language are somehow wrapped
up
in uh these feelings that we have of
lack and so forth and it's good to have
sort of a preliminary framework on which
to hang our ideas about it
uh with a footnote that it's subject to
being updated right i mean
that's that's always going to be true um
so but there's this this extra twist
that you're going to put on it that says
that
uh you know following the advice of
beyonce we should make lemonade
out of these lemons that the world has
given us
and that the lack is not just this idea
that we're driven by our likes is not a
purely negative thing that it leads to
things like creativity and expression
yeah i mean um that and that's
that is i have to admit that that's
particularly my way of reading uh like
there are other people who are much more
interested in the more destructive sides
of his theory
and i have kind of built my particular
reputation on um this
this tendency tendency to go in a more
affirmative and
and kind of i don't know sublimatory
uh so i think that you can read like on
in different ways and the way i have
chosen to read him
is that he's basically saying that
because we do have this sense of lack
and
and i want to reiterate maybe reiterate
reiterated in one other way so that it's
um maybe more convincing to the skeptics
you can think about it as a as a form of
wounding
um i i you could make the argument that
pretty much all children are in one way
and other
wounded like no one ever feels like they
are loved enough even if they had great
parents like the best parents in the
world
like you can never feel the child's need
for love
um so there's always a certain type of
wounding and then some
some people have been much more wounded
than others so
that's one way of understanding this
lack but anyway so
the idea is that like if you take it for
granted that the lag exists
then the uh obvious sort of next step
would be to say
okay well what happens to human beings
as that
and lacan came to the conclusion that um
that from black comes into being the
desire to
to fill it with various activities and
they're basically
two ways of filling it we can either go
into the world and
find things like people and of course
falling in love is one of the we can
talk about love if you want to
um because that's one of the topics i've
written a lot about um
so you can you can fall in love you can
find a person who seems to feel that
lack that's
really effective that's one of the most
effective ways of doing it
which is why a lot of people um seek i
mean if you take this theory seriously
this explains why we are so drawn to the
idea that there's like a soul mate
who's going to complete our being and
all that we can find
people or objects in the world or even
like
ideals that we hang on to as a way of
like dealing with the slack
the other route to dealing with it is to
invent something in when invent
you know any do any kind of creative
labor intellectual labor
or i don't know um like be a
carpenter or something use your use your
uh skills in such a way that you can
kind of either forget about that lag or
at least cover
it over and the idea is that a lot of a
lot of us are really good at just like
ignoring it most of the time
we make ourselves very busy and don't
want to think about it or
don't really have space in our lives to
think about it
and something like poverty would make it
very difficult to actually focus on
this sort of existential type of lack
but if we the idea is that
if we are suddenly faced with something
very difficult in our lives
like if something traumatic happens to
us
we often become very aware of it so
let's say you fall
terminally ill or you have a horrible
breakup
or something uh happens to you
professionally that's just terrible
then that then it's difficult for you to
avoid looking at that lack kind of in
the face and you can
think all the way back to nietzsche who
talked about staring at the abyss so
this is not a new idea
uh he had this notion of staring at the
abyss and having the courage to do so
and so in some ways lacan is just kind
of re-articulating this
already nietzsche an idea of like you
just have to have the guts to look at
the abyss
in the in the face rather than trying to
find these ways of
avoiding uh it at the same time as he
very much advocate
advocated the idea that they are
productive meaningful creative ways
sublimatory ways of of coping with it so
that it doesn't overwhelm you and take
over your existence and put you into a
paralysis
what was the platonic dialogue that
talked about the souls being separated
and then you're trying to find them
again was that the symposium
uh yes the symposium and khan actually
has a whole
uh like lecture series the whole book on
the symbol symposium
was plato the first laconian because he
emphasized this lack that we have that
we're all looking for to find our
our uh soul mate that has been rested
apart from us
yeah pretty much actually that's kind of
the gist of
one of my books uh it's called the
summons of love and so it's about love
and uh one of the arguments i make is
that basically
lacan is kind of plagiarizing plato
um and this whole idea that you know
zeus divided those round beings like uh
like an egg with a hair with a hair
and then they were um separated from
each other for the rest of their lives
and
yearned for a reunion with their missing
half
and then we're like super happy filled
with jesus this exuberant
happiness when they found each other
that's basically the lycanian story
except that he's very skeptical of the
ending
he's very skeptical of the idea that you
can find your soul mate and everything
will be
you know just go golden after that uh so
he doesn't buy that part of the story
but
the rest of it is just directly out of
plato so
good so i'm i'm on lakon's side and
being skeptical about the ending but
as you know uh marketing advice to
would-be
myth builders the idea of zeus and eggs
and hairs is awesome like you gotta have
that uh
extra bit of fantastical apparatus to
really catch on and become popular i
think
but uh i i wanna i do wanna get to love
because you know i'm no better than your
students who are going to fascinate
about this but i want to get other
things
out of the way first i mean you you
touched on this fact that when we do
talk about searches for ways to fill our
lives ways to address the lacks that we
have
um you know look writers and
intellectuals
when they tend to be the kinds of people
who write about
searching for meaning in life and guess
what they always say well you should do
writerly intellectual things and but
uh i want to suggest and you know i
don't know want to hear whether you
agree or not
um there's an infinite number of ways
that we can address this and some of
them might be very high brown some that
might not
be highbrow i mean you could be a fan of
a sports team or you could like
gossiping with your friends or just you
know going to mcdonald's or whatever i
mean there's
there's different sort of activities i
can imagine that are perfectly valid
uh that that are part of this
to attach too much grandiosity to them
part of this human search for meaning
absolutely and that's one of the things
that i always emphasize when i teach
psychoanalysis because i think the the
popular understanding of uh the freudian
understanding of sublimation has to do
with
very high prow endeavors such as writing
books or painting paintings or
writing songs or you know other kind of
really culturally revered activities and
i always tell my students that
that's just the tip of the iceberg that
very few people actually
deal with their their existential crisis
or their lack or whatever you want to
call it
in those ways and um i mean
i mean there are all kinds of ways in
which you can fill your life you can
exercise
you're going to have children they are
very very very good
distraction from you from your lack i
mean they take up a lot of space
very distracting you can you can watch
netflix you know
you know for days at end which i do
sometimes uh you can
uh numb your feelings with you know
alcohol or drugs or whatever
uh so there are more or less productive
ways of
of like to coping with it and i guess
the the idea in psychoanalysis is to get
people to
use um use avenues of
filling their lives that are not
pathological
in um in the normative system like are
not self-destructive are not bad for you
like so instead of like
day drinking uh doing something that is
a bit more
um like i don't know i don't want to
stay productive because it sounds like
um
like psychoanalysis is trying to like
normalize people and
this is one of the big distinctions
between other forms of psychoanalysis
and likanian theory that i should have
actually mentioned earlier
and this is why he is not so popular
with
american clinicians because most
american clinicians
are invested invested in making the
patient
more functional making uh the person
happier
more adopted social demands whereas the
goal of lacanian analysis
was to allow the patient to just like
come to
terms with the idea that they will never
feel whole
and also to question everything question
norm
question norms question social rules
rules and restrictions basically and i
hope that it's okay for me to work
can i use the f word go ahead we'll just
mark you as explicit
no problem um because i've actually used
this in writing uh
the most succinct way to
uh explain what lacan was hoping to do
with his patients was to teach them to
say
[ __ ] you to like societal demands he was
not trying to normalize anyway
any anyone so i don't want to say that
you know
he he would have been invested in making
sure that people are not
date drinking that they're doing
something more couldn't were useful with
their lives
but nevertheless i i guess i i still
have a little bit of
um of an investment in the idea that
there are more or less productive ways
of like
coping with this lack or malays or
traumatization or wounding whatever you
want to call it
yeah i mean maybe maybe you just said
everything you have to say about it but
i just want to
push harder on this because i haven't
thought about it that much myself and
i don't have the favorite answer but on
the one hand one wants to not be
overly judgy about the different ways
people have of dealing with uh
existential horror of reality um and
especially one doesn't want to just uh
valorize or privilege
uh my own ways of dealing with things so
other people can other things
but at the same time you want to be able
to say that within each individual
and their situation presumably there are
in some sense better and worse ways of
coping
right uh being a fan of a sports team is
probably better
than just drinking to forget your
problems you know at least if you don't
become too fanatic about it so
what is that judgment what is that
hierarchy that we're putting it on i
mean
what is what is the good versus bad way
of of addressing our relax
okay so now i'm gonna open a total kind
of worms good
you you started this whole podcast by
talking about truth
which of course i would expect from you
as a scientist
and uh my answer to this is that lacombe
was very invested
in this idea that there is a truth to
your desire
and he was hoping that analysis
as a clinical practice would help you
access this truth which is often um
buried or under kind of layer upon layer
upon layer of societal expectations
and so when he taught his patients or
tried to
teach his readers to to kind of resist
societal norms his
his objective was to get to something
deeper about your desire
and so the idea is that if you can kind
of locate the thing that
most fulfills your desire
in the hope that it's something that is
not destructive to you
like day drinking if you can locate that
one thing or a few things that are
most meaningful to you then that would
be the way to
uh kind of organize your life it's a
kind of a
way of thinking about self-fashioning i
need to have this idea of living your
life as poetry
what khan had had the idea of like
figuring out what it is that you truly
want
and then like following the threat of
that desire now
you can obviously it's like obvious that
there are like huge
problems with this because i mean if
your desire is to be a serial killer
you're kind of in trouble so you don't
really want
to pursue the truth of that threat of
desire but
but you know kind of beyond beyond those
kinds of extremes he had this idea that
um if you could figure out what it is
that that really appeals to you
and he had actually like a term for this
uh he called it the
object in french the object a
like the cause of your desire if you
could figure out what the object are
object a of your desire is like the
kernel of your desire
is then you can perhaps live a
life that is that feels better to you
feels more meaningful to you
uh not in the sense that you feel healed
but in the sense that you feel like
you're living
the kind of life that you want to be
living so that is sort of the
existential component philosophical
component of this
so so indeed okay so i get how it's a it
does come down to truth that in some way
when you're trying to deal with your
lack there there are ways to
truly address it and then there are ways
just to sort of mask it and hide away
and so we're gonna we're gonna
uh count we're gonna value those ways
that are a little bit more truthful is
that
fair that's very fair and this is uh
like i said
when we started talking about truth um i
say that that lacan had a very different
understanding of truth from
uh what i assume is your understanding
uh because um rather than looking for
the universal truth with the capital t
uh which in some ways he actually was
because i mean he theorized the whole
notion of lack as a universal human
condition and all of that but
but when when it comes to like specific
people individuals
uh his understanding of truth was
actually really
it had to do with the singularity of
your desire the singularity of the
the person and here i want to
distinguish between
identity which is sort of socially
socially constructed it's your
social persona that you present to the
world and then
what what i in my work have called um
the singularity of your being which has
to do
with like a combination of your
psychological life but also your
bodily drives and how you are in the
world
and um and so for him
uh or at least in my interpretation of
him the idea was
to access something about the truth of
the singularity
of your being and the closer you got to
that the closer you got to some sort of
a truth
truth about your yourself but that's
completely different from
um you know truth in in the scientific
sense of the word
because it it implies that everyone's
truth is
like specific to them well i can imagine
that
i don't necessarily think it's
incompatible i mean there
there's a truth about the fact that
electrons and protons have
equal but opposite charges and there can
separately be a truth about
individual people i mean individual
people are going to have uh
something that is different from person
to person but never less true about them
i think that's completely compatible but
this the slippery thing here is and you
know it's just it's it's not
your fault or lacon's fault it's the
fault of what is to nature
in to be a human being is that on the
one hand
yeah what in me right now there are
things that are true about me
and maybe i can try to sort of fulfill
the desires etc
but those are also malleable in some
sense right like part of me can change
another part of me and so
it's not completely clear which parts i
should hang on to and which part
i should work to change right well
that's uh i mean that's that's really a
great way to think about it uh because i
don't think that this
truth of being the singularity of being
that i'm talking about
is meant to be a static notion i said
earlier that the
the goal of analysis in some ways is to
get get you to the point where you can
quote unquote do it yourself you can
kind of keep analyzing yourself
and so there's a process to your
um way of being in the world and your uh
your singular way of being in the world
and
i've written a whole book i guess most
of my books actually talk about
uh subjectivity as a process that never
comes to an
end you're always fashioning yourself
you're always reinventing yourself
new understandings of what it is that is
important to you
come to existence repeatedly like um
continuously so it's definitely not a
fixed truth
and uh i guess one way to think about it
uh psychoanalytically or clinically is
again to get the the client or the
patient
anal assad to the point where they are
okay with the fact that they are
in constant process of becoming
something that they don't even yet
understand themselves like you don't
know what the what the end point is
going to be
and that's really hard for some people
they're looking for stability
and uh this is a destabilizing theory in
the sense that it wants you to become
comfortable and
i guess it's in some ways stabilizing
because it wants you to become
comfortable with the fact that you are
not
going to be a stable creature that you
are always in the
process of becoming something
there are some things you just can't do
from the comfort of home you can't go on
a hike
you can't go see a concert but what you
can do is exercise and with peloton
you'll have a workout experience
like no other without ever leaving home
one of the great things about peloton
is the feeling that you're in a
community that there are other people
participating struggling and sweating
along with you
so even though you have the convenience
of being at your own home
you get the common feeling that everyone
is in this together
from keeping up with close friends to
enjoying world class workouts with
people around the globe
you'll never work out alone you can hand
out high fives on the leaderboard and
join groups like working moms of peloton
or tabata for tacos so with the peloton
bike there's
nothing like working out from home learn
more at one
peloton dot com new members can try
peloton classes free
for 30 days at one peloton dot com slash
app
terms apply that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
which right which reminds me that i
wanted to ask about you know despite the
fact that we want to
not be too hoity-toity about uh overly
valuing
intellectual writerly sort of activities
there is a sense in which i think you
say that
this initial impulse of lack of trying
to fix something that we don't have or
some desire that we have for something
can be a creative impulse can actually
be seen to be at the heart of
uh our more creative moments if such
moments are what we seek to have
absolutely i mean that is that for me
personally is
uh what is most important or precious
about this theory i mean
like any theory speaks to me
theoretically but it also
speaks to me very personally i was
hooked onto it
for absolutely personal reasons and uh
it had to do with um
this kind of a jump from a feeling of
lack and alienation to
the ability to create to write i mean i
used to have a huge writing block
a writer's block in grad school you
probably even remember it
renew each other back back um back then
and uh for
a long time i couldn't write and i went
to analysis in order to be able to break
that and
it actually did work and since that i
was able to start writing
and i haven't stopped writing since
uh so and okay so i i'll i'll give you
an anecdote from uh one of lakan's
books um and uh because it will sort of
illustrate this really concretely
he's actually talking about another
analyst's text
and ultimately he says this is a
completely crackpot
kind of way of thinking about things but
you know nevertheless there's something
that we can learn from this
this other analyst that he's talking
about had a patient
who had a brother-in-law who was a
talented painter and had filled her
walls with his paintings
and then one day he came and took away
one of the paintings so
this woman was left in her apartment
with this empty spot in the wall
and she was in analysis and so
apparently this other analyst claims
that what happened was that
she went and bought some paint and
started painting herself and
miraculously actually was able to paint
a pretty good painting now lakan says
that's ridiculous there's no way that
this woman would have ever been able to
paint a good painting
from like having never attempted to
paint but the
the gist of it the fact that that she
was kind of compelled to go out and
buy paint and attempt to replace the
empty spot on the wall
was something that he could get on board
with he's like okay
emptiness we want to feel it so we find
if we have the intellectual or creative
capacity we can find
creative intellectual ways of filling
that void or
actually at least like coping with it
better but i mean so what's the what's
the programmatic advice that we have to
people who
who would like to be more creative like
lack more or i mean
i'm not quite sure uh
i'm just laughing at that programmatic
uh advice because i was like
so and antithetical to everything that i
kind of stood for because as i said
he basically spoke gibberish but okay go
ahead yeah i mean so
so i'm i'm a person on the street uh i
i've
uh i don't know what my feelings about
lacan are but i i get this idea that
uh we're driven by our lacks
even unconscious can i attach the word
unconscious to many of these things
so but i'm also writing a novel i'm
working on my novel finally uh
and i want to be creative i want to be
fun and and new and inventive
and is there a way to sort of use this
mythology as you
set up to sort of help me release my
inner creative energies
[Laughter]
there's a i'm just laughing because i
have just co-authored a book on this
very issue
with uh a novelist uh it's in dialogue
format uh
me and the novelist uh her name is
catherine quinton brower
um complicated last name um quinton
brower
uh catherine so we
wrote this book in dialogue format and
we talk about uh
the kind of logistics of creativity and
with both coming from a lacanian
perspective she's trained in the theory
as well
even though she's a novelist and so um
the conclusion that we both came to
independently of each other and i
invited to do this
project with her partly because i knew
something about her writing process
and i realized that it was very similar
to mine so i was like okay
there's something that we can talk about
here because
you know i i have written 14 books which
is a lot i know you've also written like
a
a lot but in my field 14 books is a ton
um and so a lot of people ask me you
know what is it that drives you what is
it
how is it possible that you can write
all those books and and i realized that
catherine had the same
um kind of predicament of almost like
overproductivity
and so we both came to the conclusion
that
what needs to happen is that we somehow
managed to at the opening stages of
starting to write
uh we're talking about writing
specifically but this could also apply
to other
arts um at the opening stages of writing
we purposefully kind of banish our egos
to a different room or like a different
like a mini universe we just tell
tell the ego to just like go away
and that allows uh space for
uh these sort of um physical energies
and psychological energies that i've
talked about
that i've labeled as joussons that are
kind of coursing through our bodies
to intra interact with the signifier
with the word
in such a way that the signifier is um
filled with a certain type of new energy
it's filled with a creative
innovative uh energy that is
able to create something uh
hopefully something new so the kind of
quintessential example is someone like
james choice who also wrote gibberish
and the idea is that the lacanian idea
is that
when james choice wrote he was filled
with
this energy this reassurance that was
kind of
carrying his signifiers scaring his
words in such a way that he actually
kind of demolished user
usual language and was able to invent
his own
kind of language now usually we don't
all want to do that we don't
all want to write like james choice and
write like gibberish
but uh there is i think that there's a
way in which we can release that energy
in our in our
bodies and in our psyches that helps
allows our writing to kind of flow and
allows us to kind of fly with our words
and that's something that i definitely
experience catherine catherine
experiences we kind of lose track of the
even lose lack of our surroundings we
can lose ourselves in that um
for like hours i mean i i know that
people who have called this place like
the zone
or the well they go into and stuff like
that and that feels very visceral
and so part of the the likanian theory
around life has to do with
that ability to bring the results of the
body the energy of the body
together with the signifier in such a
way that something new
comes into being and you can only do
that if you're able to banish the ego
that is sitting on your shoulder and
telling you
that you are not gonna succeed you're
not gonna be good enough your pro
sucks you're just like a horrible writer
it
means that it basically means that you
allow your yourself to write whatever
comes to uh comes to you i mean
sometimes i sit down and i write
i put my finger fingers on the keyboard
and things just start
like sentences just appear and i don't
even know where they come from
and of course the first draft is a
complete mess
but i have come to uh be able to live
with the fact that it's a complete mess
and then that allows me to
to just write and write and write until
i have a whole book length mess
and then i can take that mess and
rewrite it into a book and then the
rewriting process takes like
months and months and months because it
is such a mess uh but eventually it
turns out in
into a it turns into a kind of a
pristine
pristinely written book but the initial
initial kind of um rush of writing has
to do with just like giving up control
getting rid of the ego so that yeah
actually
that is some kind of programmatic advice
there and i hate to be the scientist but
it reminds me
of at least an analogy i mentioned
before um
uh the neuroscience of psychedelics and
you know
what effects these drugs have on the
brain one of the one of
the single most fascinating fact i
learned about about reading about these
things is
you would think that if you take
something like lsd and then you see
all these colors and whatever that it is
firing off neurons in your brain right
that it's causing these things to be
fired but in fact it depresses certain
activities in your brain it's just that
what it's depressing is the gatekeeper
like that these these sounds and light
shows and whatever
and ideas were bubbling beneath the
surface all the time
and there's parts of your brain that
sort of zero them out and
keep them silent and the taking the
psychedelics
lets them flow free so maybe that's at
least analogous
to this uh you know drug-free version
where we
learn to let our subconscious thoughts
flow a little bit more freely
yeah no i think that first of all you're
totally allowed to be a scientist
because that's where you are
in addition to being being a philosopher
and uh you know just a
renaissance man um but yeah that makes
perfect sense
uh it's precisely i mean you you kind of
nailed it it's about getting rid of the
gatekeeper or getting around the
gatekeeper
neutralizing the gatekeeper somehow and
um
there was something about the clinical
practice of psychoanalysis that
at least for me worked but that's
probably because i had the right kind of
neurosis
i am definitely not going to argue that
psychoanalysis as a clinical practice is
going to work for everyone
it works for certain types so it can
work for certain types of
symptomatic behavior i mean in freud's
opinion we were all neurotic in one way
or another
and psychoanalysis was not able to reach
certain types of neurosis or pathologies
like schizophrenia for instance or
a psychotic behavior but it was very
good with hysteria
which most of us are i mean
and so um it is going to work for
for certain types of uh neurosis and
kind of
take away uh the the rigid
rigidified kind of pathways that we
talked about earlier
relax the ways in which energy flows in
our bodies and in our psyches
and just kind of neutralize that
gatekeeper that has been
kind of instituted as uh as the
the moral compass compass and of course
we need that
in other aspects of our lives i don't
want to get rid of ethics or anything
but
we don't necessarily need it when we're
trying to write a book
so getting rid of that super ego that
would be the
psychoanalytic term getting rid of the
superego
gatekeeper is exactly the kind of
practical advice but you know as to how
you do that is a complicated question
and
it's idiosyncratic to the person who is
who is trying to trying to accomplish
that
okay good um i have two other topics
that i just wanted to touch on
i was going to say briefly but it might
not be brief we don't need to be brief
the uh the air time is more or less free
because they're big topics one is you've
written a lot and thought a lot about
mourning uh morning with a u in it the
sense of uh
being sad when something bad happens and
so uh
i mean a lot of what we've been talking
about is sort of
implicitly individualistic like i'm
working on my own [ __ ] i can say [ __ ]
now because you already said [ __ ] so
uh but then the external world uh
imposes on
us also right like bad things happen
people we love and care about
die or whatever disasters happen um how
does this
view of the of of our inner mental
landscape help us think about
those or even cope with those incidents
in our lives
okay so that's really a great question
um
i will talk on two different levels i
said earlier that
in my understanding there are kind of
two two different levels of lack or
wounding or traumatization uh
the first being the ontological and i
kind of
hesitate to call it traumatizing because
i mean if it's the
human condition i'm not sure that we
should call it
trauma but a lot of people in my field
do um
because it's like linked to this idea
that you have somehow been injured
or wounded or something in you has been
murdered by the signifier
zizek islamo zizek who has a popularized
lacan
uh often talks about the murder of the
thing
uh like and by the thing he means like
something um
um by almost like biological that that's
a
complicated uh concept that i can't
certainly talk about but we don't need
to but
okay so talking on the ontological level
uh when you think about the the idea
that
uh there is this lack in our being a
void
then the conclusion uh which someone
like julia christeva explains really
beautifully
is that actually to be a human being
is to be a being who mourns we are
always
already mourning something we are
mourning this loss that has happened to
us
at a time that we can't recall you're
right like there's no way of
actually going back to that time when
this
loss supposedly happened but the idea is
that we on some level
mourn it all the time and so christeva
has this great
quote um where she says something like
do not look for the
meaning in mourning understand that
there's only meaning because we mourn
so she's making the point that we are
only able to make meaning we are
meaning making creatures because we do
have this lack that we are mourning
and we make meaning in order to try to
fill that lack
so that's one level but then uh your
question was more
more targeted to to the other level the
the second level what i earlier called
context specific or circumstantial when
like something really horrible happens
to you
and um and freud already had
a very famous essay called morning and
melancholia
where he distinguished between what he
called normal morning
like if someone dies or you know
your lover leaves you or something bad
happens to you
of course you're going to be sad
potentially for a long time
you could mourn let's say the lost
loss of your partner your lover you
could mourn
that loss for years potentially but then
the idea is that
under normal circumstances eventually
you will get to a point where you're
able to redirect your desire to a new
person you're able to fall in love again
and find a new relationship um
but then with melancholia which he took
the post to morning the idea
is that you get stuck in your state of
mourning
uh you're stuck there kind of
indefinitely so it's kind of
mourning that doesn't come to an end and
so he thought that that was the most
pathological of the two at the same time
as he kind of also said
you know people who are depressed i mean
i think that
the contemporary term for melancholia
would be the kind of depression that
doesn't have like a clear
cause we can be depressed because of a
specific reason
or we can be kind of vaguely depressed
for no like
clear reason so when he talks about
melancholia i think he's talking about
that type of
depression and uh so um
the idea is that you can kind of get
stuck in that type of
depres depression that doesn't go
anywhere uh
doesn't leave and um so then the idea is
the psychoanalytic again clinical idea
is
that when a patient comes in with that
type of
a paralysis of mourning where you're not
able to move
move from your loss the idea is to get
you from a place of melancholic
depression
to a certain type of movement that would
allow you to start the process of
mourning that loss that you have
experienced
and then overcome over time come to the
pla to a place where you can actually
start doing something with your life so
that you're no longer stuck in that
uh what christeva calls the crypt of
melancholia
so that you can actually get away from
that
uh um you know trap of of depression
but uh and you know cognitive behavioral
theory
uh therapy i know is one way in which
people are
dealing with this obviously drugs um
antidepressants is a
like the go-to version of how to deal
with this kind of depression
in north america and that's fine i'm not
i'm not opposed to medication at all
um but but psychoanalysis is
the other other way to deal with it it's
just a much slower
way of getting there but the idea is you
go in
as someone who more i can't like
complete the process of mourning and
hopefully
through analysis you come to a place
where you you can kind of
start that process and eventually come
to an
end that allows you to then to then um
live your life more freely and maybe
part of it is just
the realization that you know if
something terrible has happened to you
the
sort of immediate instinctive reaction
that
it's all terrible life is worthless you
know i can't go on living this one thing
that was making me go
uh is no longer there and moving from
that
sort of perspective to that well i have
a reaction to what happened that is that
and there's reasons why i'm having that
reaction and it's a feature of
of who i am and so let's let's see about
how i can
adjust things to sort of deal with it in
a more productive way is that
close yeah and i mean i i think that
at the gist of it is this idea that i
mean
freud called it reality testing so
um when you're in a state of melancholia
or like this kind of depression that
doesn't go away
you basically don't want to to
acknowledge the fact that this loss has
happened to you
so you kind of keep testing reality and
um
and your your test is not very accurate
in the sense that it it
gives you back this
sense that somehow you're still linked
to whatever it is that you have lost
so you often let's say you're talking
about someone you loved
uh whom you have lost you may fantasize
that person into existence
you might actually hallucinate them like
see them on the street
imagine that you see them when you see
someone who vaguely resembles them or
something like that um
uh but the idea is that gradually you
you keep testing reality and
and bit by bit reality tells you that
this
loss is real and that you have to deal
with it and
uh and uh mourning is a process
of defecting yourself from that object
or that person um catexis is just a
fancy
term for like being bonded to something
and
uh of being invested in something and so
uh psychoanalytically when you are
mourning you're gradually
defecting yourself from whatever it is
that you have lost
and uh the successful process of
mourning
ideally gets you to a place where you
can reinvest
yourself your energy your psyche
onto a new person or new object or new
uh interest new ideals even a new
country whatever it is
um so yeah a gradual uh kind of a
decontecting so that you can reconnect
i can see why this is going to take a
long time uh the psychoanalytic version
of fixing but but it might be the
healthiest way to
to i don't know really reorient i mean i
guess
i uh now i'm just way out of my death
when we get in trouble talking about
things i know nothing about but
yeah i also am completely open to
using medication um when things go wrong
if it's very very helpful
um and for some people it's just there's
no other way i mean or there's something
wrong
you know in their balance of endorphins
or whatever it is um
but if but like we said before the
even the singularity of the individual
is not
set in stone right it can it can change
and if you can sort of
reorient who you are in a way to be more
accepting in dealing with these
terrible tragedies uh that might be a
more
long-lasting robust way to um cope with
them
yeah that's definitely the idea of the
idea again so
i i get also i'm not opposed to
medication and i do think that there are
certain circumstances where people
absolutely
need medication but the idea is that uh
um that analysis again can get you to a
point where
for the rest of your life you have the
necessary skill set
to deal with any subsequent uh tragedy
or loss or
uh whatever bad things happen to you so
that if you like figure out how to
how to deal with it once
you in some ways possess the toolbox for
doing it again
when something new happens to you i mean
it doesn't always work i mean in some
instances
a new traumatizing experience can kind
of only
deepen the wounds that you have from
previous experiences
but uh i know from my own experience
that
that uh having been traumatized and
having like figured out how
to overcome that trauma can help you
deal with new traumatization and i've
made this argument
strongly in my writing you know in like
a popular cultural
understanding of traumatization there's
often this
idea that the traumatized person is very
brittle or
fragile and can be very easily
re-traumatized
and i i always argue that that's not
necessarily the case that in fact
the the people who have been very
traumatized at various points in their
lives
often possess the right tools for
dealing with new trauma so that they're
actually more agile
and more more kind of capable of coping
with new forms of traumatization
and ideally uh psychoanalysis would give
you those tools and
uh i'll just very quickly um cite a
non-liquidian
psychoanalytic theoretician from
uchicago
uh jonathan lear who
conceptualizes this as kind of a uh
the kind of rewiring of your whole
system kind of rebooting of your whole
system
that will kind of redefine your entire
destiny
if you think about breaking the
repetition compulsion
like really getting down to the level of
the unconscious and breaking your
habitual way of dealing with things
when they happen to you you're really
talking about
reconfiguring your entire destiny not in
the sense that you are
in control of everything that happens to
you but you can you re
you reconfigure how you respond to what
happens to you and in so doing you
reconfigure uh the rest of your life um
so yeah that's one way to think about it
that i have found useful
you know i i said we had two topics left
and i was gonna do the sadder one first
you know the more melancholy one and uh
which was morning and then we're going
to move on to love which would be the
happier one but now i'm not so sure
that love is going to be the happier one
but let's do it anyway
have we have we solved love i mean plato
told us this uh
very fake story about each one of us
having a soul mate and we have to find
them and then once we do
we'll be eternally happy uh that
that seems very different than most
people's experience um
so what do we learn about love uh and
even
you can say like uh uh not love of
uh art or anything like that but love of
another person i mean
what is the insight we get from that
okay so there's
there's so much that i can say about
that and i will try to keep this brief
but
i feel like i i should have somehow i
should have just led with this because
this is as i said how i hook my students
um so they're good good news
they're bad news and good news uh i
think lykon had a very uh
complicated understanding of of romantic
love specifically
and that's the kind of love i love i'm
gonna be talking about
and there are post-likanian thinkers who
are very famous like zizek and alambadir
todd mcgowan who have written a lot
about
a love for melakanian perspective and so
okay so i'll give you the bad news first
so the idea is that um
before that kind of warning that
wounding that happens and here we are
again
in the in the realm of mythology the
idea is that
before the the wounding that happens to
you as a result of language acquisition
um
york you are kind of symbiotically
like a one being with this thing that
lacan called
the thing with the capital t uh
he took it from german dusting and you
can think all the way back to kant the
thing in itself
and uh the lycanian version of the thing
actually has direct resonances with the
uh with the kantian thing in itself
and the heideggerian thing also uh
something like a fundamentally
ontological but also something that has
to do with
sublimity in the conscience sent like a
sense like
the sublime uh thing but in this case
the sublime thing is within your being
so so what supposedly happened this
is like completely hypothetical and
completely mythological mythological but
so
the idea is that what happens to you is
that uh you kind of
lose contact with this thing
and then the thing that you are oh that
is
it's the thing and the thing the thing
the thing the thing that you're looking
for for the rest of your life the object
of your desire the object
is sort of a piece of this thing with
the capital t
and alakan didn't really have great
things to say about this
because he basically said this is the
narcissistic scenario
where you're just looking for the piece
of yourself that you found that
fantasize that you have lost and i left
i left out a really big
point earlier which which was that he
did not think that we actually ever lost
anything
when he talks about that lack that we
feel he's very clear about the fact that
we haven't actually lost anything in
reality that it's a fantasy
that we retroactively create about
supposedly having lost something
really precious so he's saying
okay so when you fall in love uh
in this way where you're looking for the
for the little piece of the thing that
you think that you have lost
then basically you're just trying to
fill your lack in a narcissistic sense
you're just like looking for
a reflection of yourself so that you can
feel whole again
so he was just like no no no that's not
how we should think about love um
but then he had this other version which
contemporary theorists have
distinguished uh from what i just talked
about they have called but i just talked
about
romance like what we understand when we
don't think about romance in the
conventional
conventional sense uh and again
like lacan they think that that's a bad
kind of a narcissistic endeavor that
doesn't really get you anywhere
ultimately you're going to be
disappointed your partner is going to
let you down because of course they're
never going to be able to be that mirror
for you
for the rest of your life you know you
you're with a person for a year
and suddenly there's like a little crack
in that mirror and you start questioning
that relationship and eventually you'll
fall out of love because it was never
based on anything that had to do
with the person the other person it had
to do with your desire to to fail your
lack
so bad bad bad but then the good version
of
love um is linked to what i
have characterized as uh as jesus
um this kind of a uh
semi unconscious uh energy that is
coursing through our being
and lacan had this idea that
when you come across a person who is
able to
kind of activate your desire on that
level on a level that is
deeper than your nurse this is the quest
for self-fulfillment
then there's something then there's
something quote unquote
real or the realistic legendary concept
to um
i will rephrase there's something quote
unquote
quote unquote truthful about that desire
and um one way to understand that is
that
and todd mcgowan is great uh great at
explaining this uh one way to understand
this is that
you are basically falling in love with
whatever it is that the other
is lacking all the ways in which the
other feels
dislocated or distorted or alienated or
lacking or not enough or whatever the
wounded or injured or whatever you're
basically connecting to the injury
in the other and there's something um
within the lycanian theory
theoretical world at least there's
something about that type of love that
actually
is like the real thing and uh but yeah
al alam badu he's a who's a contemporary
french philosopher
theorizes the so-called love event
he talks about falling in love in this
particular way
as an event that completely reconfigures
your life
so that there's no way for you to go
back to living your life the way that
you used to live
before you met the person that kind of
derailed you and it's a it's very much a
derailing
derailing kind of a uh moment
uh it's not a happy-go-lucky kind of
like i i really like this person type of
a
an experience it's like a completely
derailing
uh like uh lightning sort of
the lightning strikes you type of
experience and
it can actually be traumatizing in some
ways but once it happens
there's kind of no coming back from that
experience and that
that person is going to have a certain
hold on you
um potentially for a very long time
which also means that they have
the immense capacity to hurt you if they
decide to leave you or otherwise wound
you
you know if you're like if you contacted
bonded on that
very deep level then someone can really
destroy you
and you have to be open to that
happening yeah so the
ideally uh if you want to have
quote-unquote true or real love you
would have to be completely open to
this happening uh uh if you are afraid
of getting hurt
you kind of can't uh get the good part
so yeah it's a it's a it's a difficult
dilemma for many people which is why a
lot of people say
stay on the level kind of like safe
romance that has been sort of
socially um almost uh
pre-programmed for them like you know
what to do you go on a date and then you
buy a certain kind of gift and then you
do this and then you do that and it's
it's kind of a safe model of love um and
eventually
after a year and a half you get married
or at least engaged or whatever
and that's very different from like
allowing yourself to be derailed
by this this encounter with
other otherness in the sense that you
can never really
access the interiority of another person
completely you'll never
know exactly what it is that you're
dealing with like yourself the other is
always in the process of
evolving and mutating and becoming a
different person
so you also have to keep up with who
they are coming at the same time as you
are becoming something else
uh so it's very complicated and not
necessarily at all
uh reassuring i just want to get on the
the record here
that uh i'm very fond of my narcissistic
quest for self-fulfillment and i don't
want you bad enough like that this is an
important part of my life
but yeah but
so i i and the other but the other thing
was uh more going that was just a joke
the
the thing that fits in very well with my
experience is
i know people who have it's
even possible i've done this myself but
paper it over the memory of it
uh people who have failed in romance
because
they were too rigid in what was supposed
to happen at what moment in time
right like this thing we're doing is
supposed to happen on the third date not
on the fourth date or whatever it is and
that's clearly not a very healthy way to
go about it i mean you made the
when we were emailing back and forth uh
to get ready for this you made the crack
that uh
that laconians think of romance as just
a capitalist plot
in some way it's it's not really getting
at the essence of love right
exactly so uh again todd mcgowan uh
theorizes this beautifully because he's
very interested in capitalism
he has a whole chapter on love in his
book capitalism and desire which is a
recent book um
highly accessible to non-specialists i
really recommend it um
but yeah he he argued very he argues
very convincingly that
in our culture we have this notion of
romantic love
that follows uh very particular types of
steps that
are linked to uh basically capitalistic
uh modes of of
um uh like generating profit
so it's it's premised on things like
fancy dinners
and you know nice gifts and valentine's
day
bouquets of flowers and boxes of
chocolate and
eventually like a really fancy
engagement ring and then like the
wedding dress that costs
thousands of dollars and then the fancy
wedding and all of that and
he's just basically saying yeah this is
like uh how capitalism
has co-opted love and real love actually
has nothing to do with this
real love is something that will
completely derail you and
would kind of i mean i'm not saying that
there's anything wrong with having a
wonderful
beautiful wedding like you had but uh
the idea would be that you would not
necessarily need
that in order to to feel that
the love that you have for another
person is real and genuine
and enduring and all of those things uh
so yeah
it would be a derailing experience
rather than this kind of
let's follow the steps kind of thing and
for a lot of people it can be very
difficult to
get away from the step type of thinking
uh insofar as they have been sort of
socialized into a specific
way of being a person and of course the
whole point of lacanian thinking is to
destroy
how society has taught you to be a
person and be open to other ways of
experiencing
life and love and relationships and
yourself and your lack and all of that
so if i were to try to
dramatically oversimplify what you said
so you can you can tell me how wrong
this is but
the the message i'm getting is that
there is a sort of
mistaken or doomed way of thinking about
love in this
kind of platonic sense where you have a
lack so you find someone who feels the
lack
and there's this more uh rewarding
version of love where
we both have lacks but our lacks are
complementary and work together like
let's find a you know uh
uh the the successful couples the one
who lacked together
that's a really good way of putting it
absolutely yeah so
even though i have like throughout this
podcast i have valorized this notion of
lack in some ways
i want to be very clear about the fact
that lykon was
very very critical of the idea that you
can use
another person to sort of pluck your
your lack and make yourself whole
um he was not happy with that idea and
tried to get his
patients away from that from that way of
thinking and also
i mean as a as part of doing that
and this is why also another reason he's
not
very popular with american clinicians he
wanted to destroy your ego
that's a long story but he really did
not like the ego um
so he wants to get away from
narcissistic ways of being in the world
and i understand your defensive
narcissism i think that all of us need
some of it uh i certainly am kind of
pronounce the system in the sense that i
feel like i started my life
you know in a place where my
narcissistic understanding of myself had
been completely destroyed and then i had
to rebuild it from scratch
so i'm in the camp of the people who
believe that
we all need a certain healthy degree of
narcissism
narcissism but i can't really hated
narcissism so he was
really not uh keen on the idea that you
you use another person to feel your lack
but you're absolutely right about the
complementarity of
two different singular lacks and this is
why
one reason our like genuine desire is so
idiosyncratic and so
specific uh that only very few people in
the world can really truly
fulfill our our desire like uh in one of
my books i said something like you know
when i walk into the subway car say in
boston
the really crowded subway car
there's rarely anyone i want to sleep
with like
it's really hard to find a person i
really want to sleep with
i mean i can go through like thousands
of people and not when i sleep with any
of them and then one person comes along
and suddenly it's like oh yeah
this person this this person will do
they work yeah and there's something
yeah there's something
some complimentary something going on
and i don't understand it myself
it's enigmatic and um the khan very much
emphasized the fact that this object the
cause of your desire
is very enigmatic you don't necessarily
know what it is
in the other person that is calling upon
you or is like summoning you to
do this relationship but there is
something there it's just
you don't know what it is and if you
allow yourself to follow the threat of
that
you might get something that would be
very genuine
and um very derailing and difficult uh
but also
very genuine and and kind of growth
inducing
you know i always like to end the
podcast on an optimistic note and and
despite all expectations i think we
reached it right there
something uh genuine and growth inducing
and um
dealing with our disequilibria in
various productive ways so mario rudy
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast
thank you sean carroll
my good friend thank you so much this
has been fun
[Music]
you